hello everyone so let's discuss my video
about electric buses first off i'd like
to thank everyone for all the feedback
it's really good to see how polite
everyone was about that disagreement so
good job a second some self critique my
video about electric bosses really
wasn't that great as some people have
pointed out it felt way too shallow and
not so well thought out i agree in
general i should have been far more
thorough this follow-up video will
hopefully correct that and i think the
best way to address criticism and fill
in the gaps is to address eevblog's
video response because he brings up most
of the main recurring points i saw from
other people his video is linked in the
description so feel free to check it out
the first point i'd like to address from
eev blog is the trolleybus wires look at
these like daggy wires and sure you do
tend to like just ignore them after a
while but it's the same with that power
pulse as well if you ever lived in a
area grew up in an area with power poles
you just like you tend to ignore all the
power wires going everywhere as
then if you live in a place which has
underground power and then you go back
to the power lines you really notice
them no no thanks we're better off
without the wires so according to evblog
trolleybus wires cause visual pollution
i admit this point is completely
subjective but aren't we sitting on the
horse backwards here on the street view
image evblog points to all the wires
above saying how ugly they look if
you're bothered by that fair enough but
what about the things below the wire
it's a sea of gray and black asphalt
full of metal boxes which is the new
norm in our cities ever since mass
motorization started i feel like
aesthetic considerations about filibus
wires shouldn't be a priority personally
i think trollupus fires are fine and
this is a good example of how
modernization and tech disruption can
lead to huge societal changes like in
urban development such disruptions
extend across all facets of our society
and have revolutionized virtually every
industry except for one the art industry
antiquated opaque and difficult to enter
the art world is governed by two 250
plus year old firms rather it was until
now because there is a fintech platform
called masterworks that's turning the
art market on its head and giving access
to everyone not just the billionaires of
the world with masterworks you can
invest in the same art billionaires do
imagine buying a share in a banksy or
money artwork without having to spend
millions on buying the whole thing and
why would you want to invest in art
let's see the contemporary art prices
outpaced the standard and poor 500
dollar return by 164 between 1995 and
2020. this is according to publicly
available data when it comes to art the
folks at masterworks of course know what
they're doing since the company's
inception in 2017 masterworks has sold
three paintings each returning over 30
nettle fees to investors getting started
with masterworks is very easy just visit
the website create an account and after
a few clicks you can start browsing
masterworks also offers a secondary
market where members can buy and sell
their shares between each other much
like how you can sell stocks on an app
like robinhood diversify your portfolio
with one of the most stable assets
around especially in light of the recent
stock market disturbances if you want to
take advantage of this and invest in
some fine art there is a waiting list
however you can skip it and start
investing immediately by clicking my
link in the description thank you for
checking out masterworks ads like this
helps support what i do and now back to
the video
the ev blocks second point about olympus
wires is that they are problematic to
build out due to red tape and costs why
don't we just install the wires the
first is practicality and infrastructure
cost and the red tape to get all of this
stuff to happen you can't just go
stringing up lines willy-nilly it's not
that easy in terms of red tape that
depends fully on local regulation in
europe it's generally not a problem and
it shouldn't be that much more difficult
in other places either after all they're
putting up the wires above existing
right away unless there are some exotic
local regulations this should not be a
problem in terms of costs well more on
that later but you can see on eev screen
right here how the wires are integrated
into existing infrastructure like the
poles in my original video you could see
how they used the building's facades
trollibus wires aren't complicated to
put up let's remember this point for
later
okay so he's talking about a battery
fires if that's your argument well
diesel buses do it too and gas buses as
well the article this year why are
sydney buses still going up in flames
and what can be done about it
there it is there um it doesn't look
good does it and ironically it's the
batteries in these diesel buses that are
a good proportion of the fires in this
particular case and then there's the gas
bus uh fires as well so if diesel bus
batteries catch on fire and electric bus
batteries can catch on fire as well you
just argue in semantics really there's
just no point ev block dismisses my
concern over electric bus fires by
stating that other buses can burn down
too in large part due to the battery so
it's all semantics at that point i think
he missed my point here and in a way
also proved it of course other types of
buses can also catch on fire and of
course the battery is a large part of it
the thing is an electric bus battery is
much much bigger while i don't think
electric buses catching fire is the most
immediate problem with them electric
vehicle fires are starting to become a
problem to quote from this nbc article
on april 17th when firefighters
responded to a
call at around 9 30 pm they came upon a
tesla model s that had crashed killing
two people and was now on fire they
extinguished it but then a small flare
shot out of the bottom of the charred
hog firefighters quickly put out those
flames not long after the car reignited
for a third time according to the
article the firefighters ended up using
28 000 gallons of water to put this one
car fire out which is the amount they
use in a month and was an average
american home uses in two years in
contrast a combustion vehicle fire takes
around 300 gallons according to tesla's
first responder guide putting out a
battery fire will take between 3 and 8
000 gallons or 11 to 30 000 liters so in
the best case scenario you need 10 times
more water to put the car out tesla's
minimum amount is already more than most
water tenders can carry water tenders
are fire fighting vehicles specifically
designed to carry a lot of water 3 000
gallons is the capacity of the biggest
ones and this nets you a whole new world
of problems what if an accident happens
far away from fire stations and hydrants
what if multiple electric cars catch
fire in a pileup on the highway or god
forbidden electric bus you get the idea
so my point wasn't the existence of a
fire risk rather the severity of it this
was a minor point of mind though since
battery bus fires are not common moving
on speaking of batteries their
construction and disposal are very
polluting not to mention the occasion of
slave labor involved in the mining of
the necessary red earth metals okay if
you're going to use this argument about
electric buses you have to do them
the same and more so for electric cars
yeah
good luck with that the electric car
future is or revolution is already here
sure it's a fair point uh to bring up
and we need to probably do better in
this regard but it's not an argument
against them and that's just silly these
things can be fixed ev blog makes two
points here a if i criticize slave labor
for bebs then i have to do the same for
electric cars and good luck with that
since the electric core future is
already here first off we like really
size electric cars hell yeah i think
they suck though they suck a bit less
than combustion cars also good luck with
that you know it's possible to criticize
things even if they're becoming
widespread and popular eev's second
point i guess point b then is the
following the slave labor involving
battery production is not an argument
against bebs because it can be fixed the
position that slave labor and battery
production can be eliminated in the
future doesn't automatically give us
permission to invest into such an
industry in the present and of course
most of our gadgets contain rare earth
metals so in a way we are already
complicit in slave labor the crucial
difference though is that current
gadgets don't really have a better
alternative unless you seriously
consider living the amish life or
something while electric buses do have
that alternative in the form of
trolleybuses which have comparable costs
and need significantly less rare earth
metals further problem is that electric
buses aren't a good option where public
transit is needed the most i.e
developing countries electric buses are
much more expensive as it turns out
costing up to twice as much as diesel
buses so it's not just about the lower
initial price here and this hundred
percent uh capacity thing like you're
going to have only 50 percent the
capacity here as i said we're not
starting the city from scratch and going
oh we're going to buy 500 buses or a
thousand buses you've already got all
the existing uh bus transport
infrastructure in place you've already
got the roads the buses are already
running these are all gas powered buses
the argument is whether or not you want
to replace them with electric buses and
the uh private company that i visited
they've
done the test they've run the numbers on
it and they said
yeah we're going electric buses thank
you very much eev block says my
developing world example doesn't work
because the cities have pre-existing
rolling stock which then can be replaced
by bebs which are better on the long run
in the specific situation he described
sure within the dichotomy of beb and
diesel bus bebs can make sense we are in
agreement here but in situations where
there isn't a well-developed system when
there's just a small rudimentary network
then the main priority becomes adding
more capacity most developing countries
don't have a large pre-existing transit
network that you can just transition
into electric buses you don't even need
to go to africa for such examples kiev
and most major cities in ukraine are in
dire need of additional buses or were
before the war in the wake of multiple
revolutions and economic crises in the
last 30 years municipal bus systems were
abandoned due to a simple lack of funds
private carriers took over most bus
transit with woefully inadequate quality
and capacities they had to because very
often there was nothing else and this
problem exists even today though less
severe for example kiev has around 800
municipal buses as a 2.9 million city in
contrast budapest has around 1500 as a
1.7 million city kiev would need at
least a thousand buses yesterday the
quickest solution is to buy buses with
the lowest upfront cost even though
they're more expensive on the long run
as i've alluded to in my original video
sheer upkeep is not the only thing we
have to factor in here the lack of
public transit can cause invisible
losses that are very hard to measure but
they are there nonetheless in the case
of cave and cities like it bebs are a
good on-paper solution but city or even
state budgets are not infinite
especially when it comes to public
transit bebs might be a better financial
decision long term but a bad
socio-economic decision short and
mid-term plus the aforementioned ethical
concerns on top of this to maintain the
same capacity you generally need 10 to
20 more bebs than troll your diesel
buses depending on the charging method
more on that later so how is kiev
solving its public transit deficit well
the municipal operator plans on
purchasing 137 trolley buses or did so
anyway before the war additionally in
2020 they bought 200 diesel buses and in
2021 they announced a tender for 100
more although now they'll just be using
captured russian armor or something so
if you're in dire need of a public
transit system you should focus on
putting as many vehicles on the lines as
you can also since diesel buses aren't
much more expensive to maintain than
electric buses we can take a look at
this 2020 case study from shenzhen china
where the entire urban bus fleet was
converted to bebs according to their
findings without state subsidies diesel
buses have a lower cost of ownership
over the bus lifetime of 8 years now
diesel buses will catch up some time
after the 8 year mark but their upfront
cost is still much lower so for
developing countries that are in need of
a bus transit system most often the
cheapest option is the most reasonable
the effect that electric buses will
compensate for their costs in a decade
is little solace to the people who won't
have access to good public transit for
years to come whereas if you bought more
diesel buses for the same amount of
money you could have covered a larger
area with more lines and served more
people it's nice that electric buses
make financial sense after a decade but
that's not enough public transportation
is more than just numbers on a
spreadsheet it's transportation for the
public people in the ev community seem
to forget that sometimes so in my view
if you have two options for transit and
one is somewhat more expensive on the
long run but serves a lot more people
then people should take precedence over
sheer budget numbers you know imagine
some city hall representatives showing
up to an impoverished area with no
public transit and telling people the
good news that the city has finally
invested in public transit we have
invested in electric buses but they
won't be running here just yet since
they are very expensive we could only
buy about half the needed amount for now
with the second half coming in five
years so just five more years of
deprivation and poverty and you'll have
public transit uh why didn't you buy
cheaper buses and cover everyone instead
well
absolutely and the vast majority of
traffic pollution is coming from cars
the more buses you have ideally the more
cars you can take off the road even if
all your buses are diesel but still a
huge net reduction in total emission
which then lowers the social cost of
deaths from pollution as i mentioned
before budapest has around 1500 diesel
buses in regular operation compared to
690 000 cars in the city plus 585 000
cars in the suburbs if you're aiming to
reduce pollution you want to cut back on
car use first diesel buses are almost
nothing compared to individual motor
traffic and they give a net reduction in
emissions thus a net reduction in social
costs to sum up i agree that bebs can be
more cost effective in the long run the
data seems to bear this out but the
numbers aren't that far apart plus i
think we must consider the social aspect
as well we are doing public transit for
the people not for accountants wait did
i just imply that accountants aren't
people so for developing countries i
believe diesel buses are hands down the
best way to start for developed
countries though that can afford more
expensive hardware it's the autonomous
trolley bus assuming other forms of
transit don't make sense on the
particular route such as trams trains
and so on so in terms of trolleybuses
evlog opens with two arguments one i
shoot down my previous argument because
autonomous trolleybuses also have
batteries which can also catch fire this
one is interesting he's shooting down
his own trolleybus argument of course uh
by saying oh yeah use these autonomous
uh trolley buses which have a smaller
battery in them well if you're gonna
make your bus electric you've got the
same battery fire problems that he's uh
talked about what that's suddenly not a
problem anymore because it's a smaller
uh battery the batteries are the buses i
looked at had uh 328 kilowatt hour
battery packs in them as opposed to my
ioniq ev which has a 38 kilowatt hour so
roughly order of magnitude bigger
battery yes autonomous troll buses can
also catch fire but don't you think
there's a difference between a 30 and
400 kilowatt hour battery fire this
isn't a boolean yes battery no battery
situation we're in a spectrum here the
more you scale up the battery the more
severe your problems can get evblock
second point is the following actually
putting the wire infrastructure in place
for all this sort of stuff it's a huge
cost it's huge amount of red tape it
takes years and years whereas electric
buses you simply just drive them out
it's a complete no-brainer according to
eev's thought process if autonomous
troll bus equals yes battery and the s
wires an electric bus equals yes battery
and no wires then electric bus better
because no wires once again things are a
bit more complicated than that having a
bigger traction battery can cause
problems and complications that wouldn't
be present with a smaller traction
battery or at least they would be far
more manageable for example a bigger
battery means more weight last year
septa bought a bunch of battery powered
buses right well they sure did
and they um
they decided to deploy them on former
trolley bus routes that's where they had
electric buses that draw power from
overhead lines
um right they spit on the graves yes yes
and and and what happened
is apparently they had to take the buses
out of service last february and didn't
tell anyone and uh because all the
frames cracked
because the batteries are too heavy what
they could have used were the overhead
lines
the wires are already up we don't even
know that they put up some goddamn wires
they're already up this was just
incredibly embarrassing that like they
bought these new high-tech buses that
use worse technology than what they
already had you know it's more
extractive they need these big lithium
batteries as opposed to just some copper
wires over the street and they broke
just immediately i would also like to
add that even if we'll have lighter
batteries in the future we most likely
won't be able to just plug them into our
existing electric buses they were
designed with the battery weight in mind
so reducing it might lead to erratic
driving characteristics or the bus
tipping over in sharper curves or
something just something to keep in mind
aside from battery weight there is a
further issue you have to consider when
running buses off a big battery and
nothing else a few years ago moscow
replaced all his trolleybuses with
better electric buses and then winter
came turns out batteries are very much
susceptible to this thing outside the
showroom called weather if it's too cold
or too hot batteries lose efficiency not
only that but they also have the power
the heating or air conditioning both of
which are massive power [ __ ]
trolleybuses solve this problem by
having a separate centralized power
source which is not susceptible to the
weather unless it's a tornado or
something so it seems to me that by
forcing the power source on board of the
bus we're creating all these completely
avoidable problems for no good reason
since trolleybuses and bebs cost around
the same including the cost of setting
up their infrastructure more on that in
the end the only remaining potential
argument for battery buses is
maintenance costs and oh boy let's just
get into it i guess and here's a cost
benefit analysis of electric city buses
this has got some interesting stuff
including trolley buses now of course
you have zero units for natural gas and
zero units for diesels you don't have to
maintain the grid and charging systems
but look at this trolley bus 326
compared to five that's the cost of the
electrical grid and maintaining the
wires and the contenary uh system and
the whole like maintaining the whole
show for trolley buses so his main
argument for trolleybuses is shot down
right there wow electric bus versus
trolleybus infrastructure maintenance is
five to three hundred twenty six if
that's true that would be huge
well man i looked through this document
and comic sense title spelling mistakes
no references there is a table where
they list components of a diesel bus and
then under diesel bus it says yes in
every line and under electric bus it
says no and some very serious research
you got there besides the effects of
climate change and greenhouse gas
emissions electrica buses is the most
promising for the urban transit due to
the space occupied by the cars and
bicycles to transport the same number of
passengers oh somewhere anti-bicycle now
also if we decide to take their graphs
at face value lifetime costs of el
versus diesel are actually not that
different lifetime cost of er versus
diesel in health okay what emission
standards are we talking about because
that would be one of the crucial points
for this comparison also i have a
sneaking suspicion that they haven't
factored in the reduction in health care
costs due to having glass cars on the
road on the account of having public
transit or have they who knows there
aren't any sources and wait it says
healthcare cost of carbon what is the
cost of carbon is it emission quarters
okay so this graph electric bus versus
other transport units once again where
did these numbers come from there aren't
any references i assume all of this is
in euro they specify for bebs and diesel
but not for cng and trolley how is
maintaining trolley wires 65 times more
expensive than electric bus
infrastructure how big of a network are
we talking about how long is the
trolleybus line how many of them are
there also how many chargers are we
talking about if trolley infrastructure
really was 65 times more expensive to
maintain than how computer eastern
european countries can afford to run
trolleys what is up with this paper
anyway what is this case study of gsp
line echo1 okay ebus vs diesel bus apo 5
i guess that's cyrillic for euro five
daily exploitation cost of diesel and
electric bus okay we got tiers per day
daily maintenance registration per day
water comma electric per day so the
total for diesel is
396.44 euro per day and for electric
it's 201 yupo okay dave dave i don't
think you should be using this study for
anything really in the next part of this
video evd positive versus negative list
just like i did in my original video and
that was a mistake of mine i shouldn't
have made such a list comparison because
these things can be very manipulative
through deliberate manipulation or just
unconscious bias i might end up
overemphasizing the negatives for the
things i don't like and the positives
for the things i do like this is not
based on any hard data as you yourself
point out at best this would just be
some food for thought at worst
manipulation it's very similar to what
prageru does for example and i should
have been more responsible you did the
same thing though to which i can live
with the same criticism these lists of
hours aren't objective and don't prove
anything by themselves i believe i did
find a more reliable source for the cost
of battery versus trolley buses let's
check out this article and cost
comparison by martin wright at the urban
transport magazine he writes in the last
few years transport planners have
increasingly been concerned about the
need to move towards a low carbon zero
carbon future even for cities with
extensive electric metro and light rail
services the aim is to replace their
fossil fuels in their bus systems the
most popular answer has been to look at
the battery electric bus on the face of
it this seems such a simple and
attractive solution just buy the bus and
as the americans would say it's good to
go if anybody in a city with trolley
buses suggest that the trolleybus system
could play a significant role battery
based advocates will point to the bb and
say look no wires but in real life there
are few magic solutions the proposition
that bbs are much simpler and cheaper to
install than trolleybuses may well be
illusory after all there is so much in
common between bebs and battery
trolleybuses traction motor power
electronics for control of speed and
braking batteries and chargers are
shared in common and wait for weight
power consumption will be very similar
the main difference is how power is
transferred and stored but this does not
seem so fundamentally different that it
should lead to a significant difference
in the capital investment required right
compares three systems here b b with
overnight depot charging beb with unroot
charging and battery trolleybus of
course such comparisons can be difficult
as he correctly points out it is not
possible to produce conclusive proof
that one solution or the other is better
whatever that would mean to an
individual planner first obtaining
precise costs for the individual
components is very difficult because of
issues such as commercial
confidentiality moreover much will
depend on the individual local
circumstances of a particular city and
specific routes what does emerge from
the following is that large-scale
electrification using battery buses can
require capital expenditure of a similar
order of magnitude as for an equivalent
trolleybus system using battery's
trolleybuses with emotion charging
comparing toronto's depot charging
system vancouver's on-road charging
system and also vancouver's battery
trolleybus system pride comes up with
the following numbers as you can see
based on this calculation a betraying
robust system setup costs around the
same as an electric bus system this
article is of course linked in the
description so if you want to go over
the exact details of how this was
calculated feel free to read through it
bebs whether charged on route or in the
depot need a lot of very costly
infrastructure most of it is invisible
to the average person though while
trolleybus infrastructure is much more
apparent this might cause some people to
believe that the latter is much more
costly than deformer which is simply not
the case wright's conclusion is as
follows as all three options are of a
similar order of magnitude it is
important that transit planners and in
particular political decision makers be
aware that bebs are by no means the
cheap and simple solution that many seem
to think and conversely that contrary to
appearances and installation using
battery trolleybuses with the motion
charging can be financially competitive
with better electric buses so in the end
we can say that battery trollibus
systems are very much competitive with
bebs even in smaller towns mind you in
the czech republic ustinatlabam is a 90
000 inhabited city with 11 troll bus
lines as a side note there used to be
trend lines but those were dismantled
during soviet times as you can see even
in a city of 90 000 trollipus lines or
even trendlines can make sense moreover
there's also iflava a 50 000 inhabitant
city with seven trolleybus lines
trolleybuses can make sense even in
smaller towns not just larger cities
they are far more versatile than most
people would think alright so it's a tie
right seems like bbs and autonomous
trolleybuses are about par in terms of
costs so cities and towns are free to
choose which one makes the most sense in
their particular area right not so fast
the one huge glaring issue with electric
buses is the large-scale use of rare
earth metals which i believe is
completely indefensible today we have a
choice between two viable systems both
contain rare earth metals but one
significantly less than the other
therefore as a consequentialist i say
let's invest in the one that contains
less that way we don't generate as much
demand for rare earth metals which
ultimately means we contribute less to
modern-day slavery dave just shrugged
this point off like it didn't matter
which was a bit disappointing to be
honest this is a big reason why i don't
like electric cars either aside from not
solving any of the main problems of
individual transit such as space and
efficiency i feel like many electric
vehicle advocates tend to focus on the
tech and not the people behind it it's
nice to have a shiny new electric car
but the materials for it came from
people working in slavery-like
conditions including children for a few
dollars per day without any regard for
work safety and the idea that one day we
will develop batteries that won't need
rare earth metals therefore it's okay to
invest in eb systems now is something
that i can't accept it's this smug
textbook attitude of just hand waving
concerns yes slavery whatever elon will
just invent some tech magic and solve it
i guess don't worry about it even if we
know for certain that we will have
practical rare earth metal free traction
batteries in say five years already
imagine going down to the mines working
for bb manufacturers and telling the
miners hey folks guess what for now you
might be suffering under horrible
conditions extracting the materials for
our environmentally friendly electric
buses but soon we'll have batteries that
won't need them that means you only have
to work in this health for 5 more years
isn't technology wonderful
let's be ethical and responsible and
minimize human suffering now not in some
hypothetical future or even near future
as far as i'm concerned everything else
is just an excuse but really my
overarching problem with electric buses
is that they are very often used as a
fake solution in order to ignore
systemic problems our cities are ridden
with pollution noise and over
motorization that ruined our social
spaces but many politicians would rather
just have nicer buses running on the
same old system without ever touching on
the status quo of car dependency you
know instead of a diesel bus there is
now an electric bus stuck in the 8 lane
traffic jam in the city center we did it
folks our public transit is now zero
emission
alright so this was my follow up video
on electric buses hopefully i answered
your questions and clarified my own
position a bit more thank you once again
for all the feedback on the original
video and for keeping things civil and
of course thank you for watching and
don't forget to like and subscribe and
do check out my patreon if you
appreciate my content anyone to support
me in making it and i'll be seeing you
next time